bonsoir
je suis contre accepté ce qui va pas
m'empêcher de planter des petites
graines
dans votre cerveau
ça fait maintenant plus de cinq ans mais
avant je sais pas grand chose en fait
quasiment rien en comparaison de ce que
font la plupart des femmes j'ai bien
utilisé des capotes mais c'était surtout
à cause des ist les infections
sexuellement transmissibles
si avec une nouvelle partenaire on
estimait qu'il y avait pas de risque à
ce niveau là mais qu'elle n'avait pas
envie de ce contraceptif ont pratiqué le
retrait plutôt que d'utiliser des
préservatifs
pourtant on le sait que ça ne marche pas
bien coups de flippe pilule du lendemain
test de grossesse connaissez le tableau
et si c'est pas fiable au bout d'un
moment ça échoue évident mais on attend
souvent qu'il soit trop tard pour
l'admettre
du coup ça m'a valu d'accompagner une de
mes partenaires pour une ivg et même si
on avait accepté tous les deux prendre
le risque d'en passer par là c'était
elle qui a porté pas moi je pouvais
seulement l'accompagné
j'ai fait deux erreurs et ça m'a
questionné alors j'ai appris à faire
autrement et si ça peut servir à
d'autres c'est encore mieux
bon comme beaucoup de mecs le
préservatif j'aime pas trop ça mais
quand le risque est là la question doit
même pas se poser c'est efficace
immédiatement aussi bien pour la
contraception que pour se protéger des
ist
malgré ces avantages
la capote craquer ça m'est déjà arrivé
pas envie de compter seulement là dessus
ni de considérer que ma partenaire va
forcément prendre une pilule du
lendemain en cas de pépin
même si elle est contre accepté aucune
méthode est fiable à 100%
j'entends beaucoup de femmes dire moi je
laisserai pas ma contraception j'ai pas
envie de dépendre de mon partenaire pour
éviter de tomber enceinte je trouve ça
très bien
la question c'est comment se fait-il que
tant de mecs des lexan complètement à
leurs partenaires
probablement qu'ils pensent avoir le
choix de l'ibg alors que non les gars ce
choix là ne nous appartient pas c'est
leur corps c'est elle qui décide
du coup nous c'est en amont qu'on doit
maîtriser notre fertilité donc si le
retrait le préservatif c'est pas
satisfaisant il faut trouver autre chose
on peut réinventer les scripts sexuelle
tester de nouvelles pratiques
on peut par exemple utiliser toutes
sortes de sex-toys même quand on vient
juste de se rencontrer
ça stimule la communication
l'exploration la créativité
ceci dit j'avais pas non plus envie de
m'interdire complètement la pénétration
pedneault vaginale et j'ai trouvé une
méthode qui me convient vraiment bien
j'ai plus de spermatozoïdes dans mon
sperme
comment chez
vasectomie peut-être
ça pourrait mais non
bon comme on est en france je vais
expliquer parce qu'ici on nous en parle
peu la vasectomie c'est pas la même
chose que la castration on retire pas
les testicules du coup pas de changement
sur le plan hormonal on conserve la même
pilosité
la même musculature la même libido les
mêmes érection
d'ailleurs les testicules continue de
produire des hormones mais aussi des
spermatozoïdes simplement comme en
retire un petit morceau des canaux
déférents ils peuvent plus mélangés aux
liquides produits par les vésicules
séminales et la prostate en éjaculant
mais sans spermatozoïdes et comme ils
représentent seulement 1 à 2 % du volume
du sperme sans microscope on voit pas de
différence et l'intervention est très
simple elle peut se faire en un quart
d'heure sous anesthésie locale
dans les pays où en informent
correctement et on rend la méthode
facile d'accès on observe qu'un homme
sur cinq et un recours et même un sur
trois au delà de 45 ans
en france on en est loin puisqu'on est à
moins de 1%
mais c'est pas une question de
résistance culturelle plus ou moins
marqué c'est le résultat d'une politique
publique sauf qu historiquement les
institutions français sont nataliste et
c'est toujours le cas du coup on nous
informe quasiment pas sur la vasectomie
bien souvent même on dissuade
ce qui pose des questions sauf les
hommes qui ont au moins quarante ans de
gamin et encore
c'est le côté définitif qui braquent
beaucoup de médecins et c'est vrai qu'il
vaut mieux sûr de son choix en cas de
regret on peut intervenir ça se tente
mais c'est plus compliqué ça fonctionne
pas toujours
ceci dit s'occuper d'un gamin c'est
aussi compliqué et c'est aussi définitif
mais je suis d'accord on a aussi besoin
de méthodes réversible
la pilule masculine
ça fait déjà un bon nombre d'années que
les journaux annoncent qu'elles
devraient bientôt arriver
en réalité elle a déjà été utilisée au
début des années 80 par plus d'une
centaine d'hommes à titre expérimental
ça fonctionnait plutôt bien mais sans
rentrer dans les détails aujourd'hui on
propose une autre méthode hormonale des
injections hebdomadaires d'un dérivé de
testostérone alors une piqûre chaque
semaine ça peut sembler contraignant
mais ça évite de devoir y penser tous
les jours
il ya des gens qui en sont satisfaits et
c'est ça le plus important pouvoir
choisir entre différentes méthodes pour
que tout le monde puisse trouver celle
qui lui convient
moi j'utilise encore une autre méthode
réversible aussi la méthode thermique
d'habitude les testicules pendant le
scrotum les bourses pour être à deux
degrés de moins on les rapproche du
corps pour les chauffer légèrement tous
les jours du matin au soir ça suffit à
bloquer au bout de trois mois la
spermatogénèse la production des
spermatozoïdes
on peut choisir entre différents
dispositifs qui ont chacun leurs
avantages et leurs inconvénients mais le
principe reste le même on passe la verse
dans un anneau on y glisse ensuite le
scrotum
les testicules ont pas la place de
passer du coup il remonte tranquillement
dans les canaux par lesquels ils sont
descendus à la naissance
vous vous demandez sans doute si ça fait
mal
bah non je vous rassure avec un
dispositif adapté c'est même pas gênant
pour vous dire je trouve ça bien plus
simple de me contre accepté que de
porter ses lunettes
elle je laisse adige les br elle fonde
la buée puis elles sont fragiles s les
abîmes alors que la contraception je la
trouve confortable regardez
j'ai la porte là
mais vous vous demandez peut-être plus
tôt si ça fait mal
testicules les petites et moins
la virilité bien sûr
à la virilité cette manière bien
particulière d'envisager la masculinité
qui nous créer beaucoup de problèmes aux
hommes comme aux femmes
un homme il paraît que ça doit avoir des
couilles piètre capable de les poser sur
la table
faut être fertile générer une
descendance à qui l'homme pourra
transmettre son patrimoine et pas
seulement génétique mais aussi
économique culturel
patrimoine
l'héritage du père
quelle place pour les femmes et pour les
autres dans tout ça
réfléchissez on commence tout juste à
remettre ça en question
enfin par rapport à la peur de devenir
stérile
sachez que tous ceux qui ont utilisé
cette méthode et qui ont voulu progrès
par la suite ils sont parvenus sans
difficulté alors on n'a pas un recul sur
des milliers d'utilisateurs pendant des
décennies mais quand même ce qu'on
observe jusqu'à présent est très
rassurant ça pousse à prolonger les
essais même chose concernant la peur de
provoquer des cancer testiculaire
j'ai pas le temps d'expliquer maintenant
en détail mais sachez que je suis bien
informé est suffisamment confiants pour
continuer à expérimenter au delà des
cinq ans alors que je pourrais faire une
vasectomie je veux pas faire d'enfant
un de mes amis en est à 9 ans
d'utilisation mais tout va bien
vous douté de l'efficacité ne peut
vérifier facilement en faisant des
spermogramme on recueille l'éjaculât
dans un tube on observe au microscope et
on sait à quoi s'en tenir fantastique
non
bien sûr c'est légitime de se demander
si ça marche bien si ya pas de risque ou
d'effets indésirables il ya des contre
indications à connaître mais
rationnellement je pense pas qu'on ait
de craintes à avoir avec ces méthodes
surtout si on les compare à ce qu'on
propose aux femmes et n'oubliez pas
pendant que les hommes hésitent les
femmes elles continuent d'expérimenter
ce qu'on leur propose
malgré les risques avérés alors pourquoi
pourquoi si peu de gens connaissent et
utilisent ces méthodes
il ya des raisons intimes individuel
mais aussi des raisons structurelles
politique dans une société encore bien
sexistes et à la médecine s'octroie
beaucoup de pouvoir sur les corps des
femmes
pensez aux luttes féministes des années
70 pensez à la gynécologie et
l'obstétrique
et témoignages de violences sont
hallucinants on n'intervient plus
prudemment sur les hommes
on sait qu'il ya des pistes
intéressantes à creuser mais le sujet
est délaissé
la contraception ça obéit à des logiques
de marché est ce qu'il ya de l'argent à
gagner
les vendeurs de molécules pense que
c'est en concurrence avec la
contraception des femmes en réalité deux
précautions valent mieux qu'une et c'est
important que chaque personne puisse
maîtriser elle même sa fertilité
l'état aussi a du mal à investir
ça coûte de transformer les services de
santé
formé le personnel financer la recherche
informer et même éduquer à prendre aux
ados comme aux adultes que la
contraception c'est pas juste pour les
femmes on doit travailler collectivement
les notions de liberté d'égalité de
responsabilité
mais comptez pas sur les institutions
pour faire pour prendre beaucoup
d'initiatives à ce niveau là
souvenez vous les femmes ont dû
batailler ferme pour obtenir le droit à
la contraception et à l'avortement
alors maintenant
réfléchissez bien
si la contraception est une liberté
pourquoi seules les femmes pourraient en
bénéficier
et si c'est une responsabilité
pourquoi elles seraient les seuls à en
porter la charge
maintenant vous cernez mieux les enjeux
si on veut pouvoir utiliser ces méthodes
si on veut transformer la société avec
ça ça va pas se faire tout seul des
associations des collectifs s'organise
sites les plus impliqués pour que vous
sachiez vers qui vous tourner le
planning familial haarde et comme les
thomas boulou gars qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement on
diffuse les informations dans différents
événements ou sur internet on rédige des
lettres ouvertes pour interpeller les
institutions on répond aux journalistes
on s'adresse aux professionnels de santé
pour les inciter à se former on
intervient dans les universités dans les
lycées et aussi c'est vraiment important
on accompagne les gens au plus près dans
leurs démarches de contraception quelle
que soit la méthode ou dispositifs
qu'ils envisagent on propose par exemple
des ateliers couture pour les aider à
fabriquer eux mêmes des dispositifs
contraceptifs qui ressemble à ça
s'en servir correctement
avec ça on favorise l'autonomie la
responsabilité on incite à l'action
individuelle et collective tant pis si
les institutions sont pas prêtes on
avance on sent que ça répond à une
attente de beaucoup de gens
sachez qu'il reste encore beaucoup à
faire avant que ces méthodes soient
accessibles et vous pouvez y contribuer
de tout un tas de manières
saisissez-vous du sujet
informez-vous davantage on a un site
internet
pousser les réflexions provoquer les
discussions et surtout expérimenté
vous pouvez aussi créer un groupe là où
vous habitez pour amener les savoirs et
les savoir faire au plus près des gens
qui en ont besoin
si on se donnait plus de moyens pour
faire l'amour
serait peut-être un peu moins la guerre
alors merci de soutenir ce qu'on fait
d'y participer à votre échelle et à très
vite
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]